you
[Music]
okay hello everyone welcome to this
candidate torque by Cameron mu skill so
Cameron is currently a grad student from
MIT supervised by Nancy Lynch
he works on large-scale algorithms
across a number of fields ranging from
like numerical linear algebra such as
for like lentils method for PCA such as
like low-rank approximation and so on
and also he has worked on some linear
time algorithms for also for lowering
approximations and so on
and he recently also started to work on
social network algorithms and as he also
has interesting biological computations
and so on so this talk is about the
power of simple algorithms from data
science to biological systems ok yeah so
today I'm gonna be talking about the
role of simple algorithms and data
science specifically I'm going to talk
about why really simple often randomized
methods like stochastic gradient descent
and random hashing random sampling are
so powerful and so ubiquitous and data
applications and I want to overview some
of my work in this area so specifically
I'm going over you some work on a new
class of sampling algorithms for linear
algebraic computation but let us do some
really powerful and surprising things
like for example something your time
low-rank approximation for matrices in
some really nice thing so i'm an
overview my work on on sort of investing
in these algorithms and especially their
role in linear algebraic computation and
then if i have some time at the end i'm
going to talk about some connections
with biological systems and trying to
understand when we're studying really
simple randomized algorithms really it's
all about figuring out how small
stochastic interactions can lead to some
sort of complex behavior and i'm gonna
talk about how insights from this could
be used to study beyond algorithm design
but algorithms that are being conducted
in nature and specifically some
decision-making algorithms that ants use
alright so we all know that data science
and machine learning are huge consumers
of algorithms and we also know that
algorithms aren't just a nice to have
fast algorithms aren't just saving us
resources they can really lead to
breakthroughs in these areas
the thing that's probably at the
forefront of a lot of people's minds for
example is the success of deep learning
and neural nets for image classification
this has been driven forward by a lot of
many advances one of them being that we
can just scale these networks to huge
datasets and also just a huge model
sizes so that's really a computational
breakthrough that's driving a learning
breakthrough in genomics the same things
happening basically with we can do
genetic sequencing way faster than we
could do before and this is a
computational breakthrough basically
we're able to take a bunch of short
reads of DNA and stitch them together
massively in parallel and therefore
generate more data for ourselves and
actually generate the ability to get
insights from this data so these are
just some examples another one is like
in remote sensing the ability to do
real-time hazard monitoring this has
been driven by computational advances so
computational advances mattered not just
for saving resources but really to drive
breakthroughs in learning and science so
what do we need from algorithms if we
want to design algorithms that help push
these advances and actually like push
forward science and learning what do we
actually need from these algorithms the
first thing is sort of a given it's just
if you're an algorithm designer like me
this is what you're always looking for
you want fast algorithms and if we're
gonna run them on big datasets you want
things that run say in linear time and
are just extremely fast and easy than
that but the other thing is a little bit
less defined we somehow want the
algorithms that are gonna actually have
impact on practice or algorithms that
are somehow flexible and simple there
are things that we can adapt to like a
wide range of application domains they
work well on lots of different input
types they work well when you tweak the
problem that you're trying to solve a
little bit or tweak the model that
you're trying to train a little bit and
they'll also work well in lots of
computational environments and they're
easy to implement and lots of
computational environments so a lot of
computational advances aren't driven
necessarily about how girl design but by
system design and we want our algorithms
to fit in with this we want things that
it's not hard if there's a whole new if
there's a new distributed system that's
become popular it should be easy to
adapt the outer into the system it
should be easy for people to implement
and test and actually bring up to speed
and so sort of the thesis of this talk
in of a lot of my research is that
really simple randomized methods often
satisfy these criteria that we're
looking for of being simultaneously
really fast but also being easy to
implement flexible robust and all these
types of things so I'll just give you a
couple
examples of sort of really common
randomized algorithms that are used in
machine learning at data science the
probably the most the most well known
one is stochastic gradient descent you
start gradient descent is already pretty
simple I'm trying to optimize a function
in every step I walk in the direction of
steepest descent and I eventually
converge towards the minimum or a local
minimum in stochastic gradient descent I
just say I don't want a computer full
gradient maybe I just want to look at
one data point at a time and compute a
gradient based off that some really
coarse estimate of the gradient which is
correct and expectation so I have this
gradient Tilda which is correct and
expectation but might be really far off
and I might not really correlate that
strong in the theory yet I can still
take small enough steps in these
directions and eventually find that I
converge to a minima and this is a
hugely applied algorithm why is it so
popular one it's applicable to a really
wide range of problems just like
gradient descent is you can sort of
throw it at any optimization problem you
had and see what happens
it's really naturally distributed its
naturally streaming the steps that you
take are really cheap and this is a
really nice thing in practice you don't
have these big expensive steps you have
really cheap many steps going on at once
and we also some theoretical
understanding of it at least for convex
functions we don't understand exactly
why it works for all functions we apply
it to but by having because it's simple
enough we can really do some analysis on
it and try to use this analysis to
understand what's doing to understand
how we like to modify it and improve it
and things like that another example are
Markov chain Monte Carlo methods they're
sort of like stochastic gradient descent
and you can in that you can throw them
at tons of problems and see what happens
they take really simple steps on trying
to sample from a distribution I just
need to say compute ratios against this
distribution and take relatively simple
steps and they're easy to implement it's
not if I want to implement one of these
methods and a number of systems it's
easy to it's easy to do and then in my
final example which is quite close to on
my own research is random hashing and
random random feature hashing and random
projection basically this is I have like
a large data set for whatever reason I
have many data points for many I have
many features and I randomly compress
this data set using some sort of random
hash so what I mean is literally I
randomly take features or I ran and we
take examples and I add them to
gather maybe with some appropriate
weight function another way of viewing
this is I generate some random matrix PI
from some distribution and I compress my
matrix with it I take a and I multiply
it by PI and apply this random linear
compression and I hope that I get
something useful out I hope that this
compression a tilde I can then use and
downstream applications for things like
clustering or PCA and things like this
again this method applies to a huge
range of problem it's a sort of a very
generic pre-processing method almost
like PCA in a way where you can apply it
you can shrink the size of your data
then you can see what happens what
happens to your results it's naturally
distributed it's based on basically just
doing matrix multiplication which is a
super easy thing to implement and is
widely implemented it basically
implemented in any any system that
you're going to be using and again
because it's simple I mean we have it
takes some math but we have good
theoretical balance for it and we have
some good theoretical understanding of
it based on sort of Johnson Linda's
trial type results and random matrix
theory we can actually sort of figure
out what it's doing and why it might be
working well okay so also mention that
all these algorithms I mentioned in
other randomized algorithms these simple
randomized algorithms come with other
advantages they take small local steps
often this is certainly true of
stochastic gradient methods and this
makes them sort of more tolerant to
noise and perturbations for example
there's a lot of work on stochastic
gradient descent and asynchronous
systems and where you you basically have
perturbed behavior because you don't
synchronize the processors running the
steps very very well and you still seem
good and you still see good behavior in
these systems so these algorithms can be
perturbed and seemed to still work well
they all aggressively trade
approximation for efficiency so all the
ones that I mentioned are approximation
algorithms randomization and sampling
and sketching naturally lead to
approximation algorithms and the good
thing is is that often in da top
locations there's not some canonical
answer we're looking for
we have noise over the data anyways and
by trading off by allowing ourselves
some approximation we can get much more
efficient algorithms and then something
that I mentioned while I was talking
about these is a lot of these have
relatively clean mathematical analysis
as basically probabilistic processes
with random sketching
yes it's an algorithm but what you're
really doing is you're saying I have a
random matrix
that I generated I applied this to my
dataset what's the effect of this random
linear map on my data set and so it's a
rather simple thing to sort of try to
pin down and figure out what it's doing
okay so this has been the goal of a lot
of my work is to basically build out the
toolkit of these simple and
general-purpose randomized methods for
data problems and also our ability to
understand exactly what they're doing in
to analyze them in my work as anyone
mentioned touches tools in theoretical
computer science also in more
traditional and numerical computation
and optimization feels so one thing I've
been interested in especially interested
in is for example so Casta gradient
methods which i talked about before
i've been interested in understanding
how these methods can be applied to
linear out the problems canonical
problems in linear algebra which are
useful for data science so one thing
I've a lot of times we have bounds for
stochastic gradient methods for convex
problems things like solving linear
systems but we don't necessarily have
bounds for other problems for non convex
problems and what I've looked at is
combining these methods with tools from
numerical linear algebra like real life
subspace methods and using these to sort
of boost the power of these algorithms
to try to solve things like eigenvector
approximation spectrum approximation
certain forms of regular acid regression
to try to expand their use in linear
algebra and data science and this is
required turning back to these older
tools like Krylov subspace methods and
understanding how do they play with
noise and approximation how are they
robust to this noise another piece of my
work is understanding random sketching
methods for linear algebraic graph
problems and data problems like
clustering in low-rank approximation and
Adeem of my work here has been trying to
understand given a random projection
method or a random hashing method how do
I really characterize I'm taking my
matrix and I'm randomly compressing it
and then I'm gonna do an operation on it
what is the right way to characterize
what the compression does to my matrix
and how it approximates the original
data and then if I can characterize this
on a really nice clean way then I can
use this to give applications to lots of
downstream problems so this has been a
focus of my work there
and then a huge amount of my work has
been on sampling and sampling is mostly
what I'm going to talk about today
basically trying to figure out what is
the right way to sample for linear
algebraic India problems and what I'm
going to focus on today is a line of
work which is focuses specifically on
important sampling methods in graph
algorithms and linear algebraic
algorithms and sort of a new class of
methods which don't fall into the range
of stochastic iterative methods they're
not quite the same as random sketching
although they're certain there's certain
similarities and they allow us to do
some really powerful things for
canonical problems like lowering
approximation or linear system solves
and then if I have time I'll touch back
on this connection to biological
computation and some work that I've done
on stochastic decision making in ant
colonies and how we can analyze this
behavior using a distributed algorithmic
perspective and using a lot of the same
tools we use to analyze the algorithms
that we ourselves design okay let me
just briefly overview so as you noticed
in this last slide a lot of my work is
on computational linear algebra and
specific computational linear algebra
focus on data problems so let me just
briefly overview the role of
computational linear algebra in data
science and why I think it's such an
important area of algorithms to be
looking at basically data is often
represented as high dimensional real
valued vectors and when this is the case
you can represent your data set as a as
a real valued matrix with n rows
representing the data the data points
and D columns representing the features
and then transformations on this data
naturally become linear algebraic
operations so things like principal
component analysis spectral methods and
nonlinear dimensionality reduction
kernel methods linear models these
things are all really bread-and-butter
linear algebraic operations that we run
daily on data problems and they really
come down to figure out how to do basic
linear algebraic computation faster the
paradigm of working with data through
matrices and through linear algebra is
so prevalent that often we have data
that we can't write quite representing
this form and we actually try the
Trenton we try to transform it so things
like word embeddings and words effect or
spectral embeddings for graphs and
things like deep walk this is such a
power
for computational paradigm that we often
try to fit things into it even when they
don't seem to fit in initially and this
is because we have a lot of really
powerful computational tools in linear
algebra that we can use to our advantage
for processing data okay
in many applications of linear algebra
boil down to two core problems there's
the really core problems like
multiplying matrices together
multiplying matrices with vectors but
then beyond those they're sort of two
really core problems that at the heart
of a lot of what we do and these are the
problems I've sort of focused on in my
research one of these is solving linear
systems so solving linear systems you
might think of as applying the inverse
of a matrix to a vector another way to
think about this is you're just trying
to solve this minimization problem we're
trying I'm given a matrix a I'm given a
target vector B and I'm trying to find a
vector X that minimizes the difference
between ax would be its like ordinary
least squares regression it's used as an
internal loop in things like we really
rated least squares for generalized
linear models it's used inside of
interior point methods and also its
equivalent to like a projection problem
a the columns of a sort of define a
subspace the column span of a ax is some
vector in that subspace and what we're
looking for when we solve this problem
is we're looking for the vector ax the
the vector in that subspace we're just
closest to our input vector B so this is
a really basic if you're working in
Euclidean space and you're working in
sort of with a vectorized data this is a
really basic operation that you need to
have you're figuring out how close a
vector is to a given subspace and then
the other problem that I've focused a
lot on are computing the top singular
vectors of a matrix or computing the top
eigenvectors of a matrix basically you
want to find the singular vectors which
correspond to the largest singular
values in a matrix
or how this is often viewed at a high
level as you're trying to find the
directions of greatest variance in your
data and the reason you want to do this
is usually you end up 4j at some point
you end up projecting to those dimension
those directions basically you end up
approximating your data set by just
looking at the directions of greatest
variance this is the basis behind pca
spectral methods a nonlinear
dimensionality reduction one way that i
like to view this problem is we don't
actually care about finding the direct
well sometimes we do but we don't always
care about finding the
actions of largest variants we don't
actually care about finding v1 through
VN e well we often care about is just
that we capture most of the variants
overall so what we do is we use these
directions to generate something like a
low-rank approximation so specifically
if I let V be the matrix whose columns
are my top case singular vectors those
are the directions of greatest variance
in my data if I project my matrix to
them so I form this matrix AV V
transpose
I've drawn this out here this is like a
thin matrix a V times a wide matrix V
transpose where yeah this is the minimum
this is the rank K matrix which is
closest to my matrix in a bunch of norms
for example the Frobenius norm where I'm
just adding up the sum of squared
entries now this is really often times
why you want to use computing the top
case singular vectors because we find
that in practice a lot of matrices are
close to low rank or at least they have
decaying spectrums and you can
approximate them reasonably well by low
ranked matrices and so this is exactly
why you compute these singular vectors
you project to them so that you can
approximate your matrix as well as
possible with a really concise low rank
representation another way of thinking
about this is you just find a projection
of your data that preserves as much
structure as possible basically by
hoping that by getting a matrix as close
as possible to your original matrix you
preserve as much structure as you can so
that's how I'm going to think about this
problem I'm not going to focus on these
singular vectors themselves I'm going to
focus on sort of the main reason we care
about these singular vectors which is
computing low-rank approximation okay so
how do we solve these problems these are
these two problems linear systems and
top singular vectors they're sort of
actually very closely tied together how
we solve these problems they're sort of
the textbook direct methods like things
you would learn about like Gaussian
elimination or it's true Leske
decomposition there's a lot of work in
this area these things take a long time
for an N by n matrix they take n cubed
times so you can't run these things on
large matrices they are really important
algorithms because you often run them as
sort of subroutines on smaller matrix
all of my all of my algorithms will use
these sort of direct methods of
subroutines but we'll run them as small
on small samples of our original matrix
but you can't just go and run them on a
large matrix it's just not possible
iterative methods are
things like conjugate gradient for
linear system lanzhou Smith is gradient
descent for linear systems these things
basically their basic operation is doing
a matrix vector vector multiply and they
use some iterative approach to try to
get closer to the solution to a linear
system or solution to some I in vector
with each iteration being a matrix
vector multiply these things are
generally much more efficient than
direct methods you can actually run them
on large matrices you can distribute
your matrix vector multiplies but again
every multiplication that you perform is
doing a full pass over your data so
there's still something that there's
still a question of is this really the
best we can do we do we really need to
make a full pass over the data for every
single iteration and so my work sort of
falls in a third category of algorithms
which has only sort of recently come to
recently grown up in some way the
methods here are randomized so things
like compressing your matrix with random
hashing or random projection so cast a
gradient set what I mentioned and random
sampling which I'm going to talk about
in this talk these things are trying to
sort of access your matrix in a very
local or limited way not do a full pass
over your matrix for every iteration and
they're trying to exploit this to get
faster run times you can often get
really fast surprisingly fast around
times like one thing you see sometimes
quoted is you can get run times of the
forum and nza so that's the number of
non-zeros in your matrix so if I if I
sparse toward my matrix as a sparse
matrix this would be the time it takes
me to read my matrix just the list of
entries plus some lower order terms like
depending on lower dimensional terms so
for low-rank approximation for example
you can get run times of the form order
n n za basically order one reads of my
matrix plus some term which depends
polynomial on D the dimension and K the
the rank of the approximation that
you're doing and so these can be a lot
faster than iterative methods which may
which require many applications of
matrix elimination many things that cost
n nza if you're doing sparse matrix
multiplication and as I said they
typically access the matrix in a very
limited or local way so that's why I'm
gonna be talking about today and
specifically I'm gonna talk about sort
of the simplest way you could imagine to
speed-up matrix computations which is
random subsampling
you give me some large matrix
I can't afford to run a direct method on
it I can't afford to run internet on it
what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
subsample it down I'm gonna select
uniformly some subset of the rows which
correspond to data points or I'll select
some set of the features and I'll hope
for the best times number three so in
typical applications for laity because I
don't know problems what should I think
it would be is it like candidates or i3
it sort of depends it shouldn't be like
three but it's probably dozens or maybe
hundreds I mean it sort of depends
people use these methods on problems
that they can solve with these methods
so in the case that you can actually
solve the problem well it's maybe dozens
or something like just like unreasonably
yeah it sort of depends I guess what the
constant factors on that nsz bound are I
mean so iterative methods yeah I don't
mean to trash on them there's still like
a very active area of research and
they're like I think that there's a lot
of there's a lot of work on iterative
methods in numerical computation
community that like could be used in
data people use yeah they use these
things yeah so yeah usually so the
number of iterations depends on the
accuracy though usually though the
iterative methods are much more accurate
in some sense than these randomized
methods so usually you can if you make
some assumptions you get like linear
convergence whereas these randomized
methods usually you're paying you're
taking samples and you need you get some
sort of like worse convergence you need
to take more samples to get higher
accuracy yeah these things also play
really nicely together so this is one
reason I mean you can often use
randomized methods to accelerate
iterative methods like randomized
preconditioning you can combine
stochastic gradient method with them so
they play nicely together yeah yeah so
random subsampling this is what I do
what I do if I don't know what to do I
could just sub sample my matrix down and
then I could hope that working on the
sub sample matrix seems to work well and
this is used all the time so if you have
this is used all the time for example in
exploratory data analysis I want to test
out if a model works I just sub sample
my data points I run it on a much
smaller set of them and just see what
happens it's also used with feature
sampling so for example in genomics they
have more intelligent ways of selecting
features but there's always some massive
feature selection process first or often
some massive feature selection process
first before any real analysis any
further analysis happens so this is a
really prevalent method the problem is
that if you're just doing uniform
sampling this is really cheap but it's
also wasteful in a way as you can see
you're just throwing out things you're
throwing out information and throwing
out data points you're throwing out
features and often the sample doesn't
well represent your matrix so a simple
way to see this is if I have a clustered
data set say with some imbalance in my
clusters I might not know these clusters
but sort of they fall into my data falls
into these three clusters and one of
them is a lot bigger than the other ones
then if I do uniform sampling I'm gonna
tend to get more points in that cluster
and I can easily miss like all the
points in this third cluster and for all
I know those are the points that really
matter maybe those are the features that
really contain a lot of my notes so you
know from sampling can be problematic
and for this reason there's tons of work
on figuring out well what should we do
instead of uniform sampling they're sort
of clustering and distance based methods
if you've heard of them there are these
things called determine on top point
processes which are a really nice way of
formalizing selecting sort of diverse
sets of points or features there's
classification based methods where you
sort of run classification using small
subsets of the features and use this so
there's lots of things I've been
studying here for example with this
problem the solution really went in this
case the solution want to be super hard
I could cluster my data first I could
explicitly identify these clusters and
then I could like rebalance my sampling
to try to get enough points in this
cluster so this would sort of overcome
the issue with uniform sampling so these
non uniform sampling approaches these
sort of important sampling approaches
often work really well in practice but
the issue is that they're really it's
really hard to define exactly what makes
a good sampling scheme we can run a
sampling scheme we can see what we get
as far as classification accuracy or
some downstream thing and we can declare
that it's good for that problem but it
makes the sort of hard to develop sort
of generic methods like I was saying at
the beginning of this talk that are
based on sampling it makes it difficult
to understand well how can we get these
to work for many problems at once and
how can we prove that this is the case
so in a sense they're sort of inherently
here
mystic or ad-hoc because we don't have
before we have a good definition of what
a good sampling is okay so that's sort
of the goal of my work on sampling which
is basically to understand what is the
right way to select feed theater points
or features for generic linear algebraic
computation to do fast approximately a
hundred computation in this is obviously
an interesting question for all sorts of
algorithms and learning in optimization
I'm focusing specifically here on linear
algebra I want some generic sampling
method that lets me speed up like
solving linear systems low-rank
approximation a lot of the standards of
those computational tools okay
so the first step is that in designing
such a sampling schemas we're going to
restrict the types of schemes we
consider specifically we're going to
only look at schemes which are
relatively simple random processes I'm
only gonna look at sampling schemes that
look like this I assign some sort of
score some probability between zero and
one for every row in my matrix this
represents the sort of importance of
that point in the composing of my matrix
or my data set which I'll explain how we
compute these later and then what I do
is for every point I just sample it
independently at random with probability
P I and so it means that once I have
this important sampling distribution set
my sampling process is super easy it's
just flipping a bunch of biased coins
and this gives me my sample from my
matrix and then I'm gonna hope that this
sample somehow well represents my
original data in some sub metric and
we're gonna analyze the effects of the
sampling I'm not going to get into us
out altering this talk but we're gonna
analyze this as a random process we
review selecting these points as
basically choosing a random sampling
matrix and applying it to our matrix
we're just selects out individual rows
of the matrix this is like not it's not
a huge technical innovation or anything
like this
but be doing random sampling make some
houses way easier than for example we
could have computed all these scores and
then just selected the points with the
highest scores or something like this
but these things become really difficult
to analyze here we just have a really
simple independent sampling process and
that's how we're gonna how we're going
to try to approximate our matrix
okay so then the question becomes how do
we compute these probabilities P I so
naturally you think well it depends on
the problem I'm trying to solve so for
linear systems I'm trying to solve this
problem minimize ax minus B what I might
want is that after I sample my matrix so
I instead solve the problem on working
instead solve the problem on si the
sampled version of the matrix and SB the
sampled version of the output vector I
might want this to give me a reasonably
good solution maybe it's a near minimum
fire my original problem so this is I
would I would try to look for sampling
probabilities that guarantee that this
is gonna happen with good probability
for low-rank approximation I might ask a
different thing I want to sample my
matrix so I have this matrix si my
sample matrix I want it's going to be
much smaller than my original matrix I
want to compute it stop singular vectors
and then I want to project onto them
compute this avv a vs vs transpose this
is a low rank matrix if I say if the if
vs has K columns this is a K rank matrix
I want this to be a near optimal
low-rank approximation if I if I look at
all rank K matrices
this one's nearly as close as possible
to my original matrix so this is a sort
of optimization viewpoint of how can I
solve this products approximately well
the problem is is that if we start going
through all these various problems it
seems like we're going to require
different sampling distributions and a
sort of different analysis for every
single problem that that we're trying to
solve and this isn't what I want I want
something that's very general just like
you can do very general analysis of
things like surpassing gradient descent
I want something that applies to a huge
range of problems at once so you can
just take the same problem the same
algorithm and apply it to a bunch of
different problems in the key idea here
is also pretty simple but it's pretty
powerful is that instead of looking at
problem specific guarantees or I want to
approximate this problem a probably
nearly optimally we're going to look at
really simple spectral approximation
guarantees but this means is I'm going
to ask for any vector X I'm going to
want to preserve the product with my
matrix I'm going to want to preserve the
product a times X so specifically if I
look at the product of my
Apple matrix I want this norm to be
close to the norm of the product with
the original matrix and I'm allowed
myself to types of error I'm gonna have
this epsilon multiplicative error so
it's closed multiplicatively and then I
also I'm gonna allow myself some
additive error in terms of this lambda
parameter which says even if for example
a X was zero I'm gonna pay I'm gonna
have still maybe I might not get exactly
zero out when I multiply by s a X this
is like a really simple linear algebraic
guarantee it's just saying how close a
and si are at when they act as linear
operators so I'm basically say I'm
applying these matrices to vectors and I
want to make sure that they're doing
pretty similar things and the nice thing
is that this sort of guarantee it's easy
to write down in you can then start
playing around with this guarantee and
you can show that it can be used if si
satisfies this guarantee for example if
it satisfies this guarantee with lambda
equals 0 you can use it to get epsilon
approximate linear system soccers or
preconditioners for the nearest for
iterative system methods if you increase
lambda to the appropriate value you can
use this to get near optimal low-rank
approximation algorithms you can use it
to get approximation algorithms for
constrained optimization things like
non-negative PCA and k-means clustering
and this has been a lot of it's sort of
a simple it seems simple right map this
guarantee to all of these problems is
not necessarily that simple and you have
to it's not necessarily always as simple
as it looks and a lot of my work has
been focusing on what's the right way to
map this guarantee to giving
approximation bounce for all of these
problems but yeah it does seem to be a
harder condition but sort of in the end
for example for linear systems yeah in
the end it it seems to turn out that the
results we can get match what people
were getting if they just targeted those
specific guarantees and we often get
Rinty is that you would be so imagine
for the love of invention but yeah
it seems to be the oh yeah that's true
this isn't yeah there's certain problems
where this is definitely not necessary
yeah for the two problems I mentioned
this is almost like tight in a way like
you better be getting this yeah yeah
well because this is sort of preserving
the spectrum of your matrix but yeah
you're right for some problems you might
this might be overkill yeah yeah I'm
kind of surprised that what you want is
to preserve the norms
I would have thought it'd be something
like the difference between the two
projections instead of that you want
their norms to be similar like yeah so
if you just preserve the distance you
you mean the difference between their
two subspaces span by these turn around
like si X minus ax and then something
about like that that being you know not
too large yeah I mean so yeah it's a
little bit of Hearts OS ax and ax are
like different size of things so you
have to have like a certain right way of
defining this but for example this means
like I preserve distances between if I'm
looking at a X minus a ey I'm also gonna
this is gonna be approximately by SI x
minus sa y the norm the norm will be
this little X make the norm hopefully
not the actually the norm not the actual
direction yeah yeah but generally yeah
yeah I won't person it won't approximate
the actual direction yeah it's a little
hard to say what it means to approximate
the Durrett yeah it sort of depends I
mean yeah SI x + ax live in different
spaces so it can be a little it's a
little hard to find that yes yeah yeah
okay
and it's a little Estes by every
variable this is also for every vector
which is certainly not necessary I mean
often this is what we want but this is
not necessary that all the time and for
example like Johnson Linda Travis type
results are doing this not for every
vector and they can often do something
much more efficient they only care about
say I have a bunch of vectors I'm trying
to compute closest distances I only care
about preserving this for all those
vectors in my dataset not for every
possible vector if you have a data point
repeated like ten times what are this
prints of presumed is going to drop nine
of these occurrences read keep only one
right so can you explain why this does
that so if I have if I literally have
ten exact repeats of my data points and
I if if I knew that I had ten exact
repeats it's going to drop or all but
one and also s is going to be I guess I
didn't mention this but s is also going
to reweighed data points it relates by
the inverse of the probability I
selected them so if I literally like
exactly new I select them with
probability one tenth they will
reweighed them up by one over that
probability by a ten factor
so actually what I'll do is all exactly
preserve the norm I basically compress
those all into one row of my matrix so
this is when it works like really well
yeah and if I have a bunch of for
example really small data say I have a
bunch of data points that or I don't
know if we should be thinking about
these it's hard to just call them D so
you have a bunch of rows in my matrix
that are really small they're very small
norm they will attend a very small dot
products with my vectors X and those
might for example just be dropped all
together in that case might go into this
additive error term this lam - okay any
other questions on this yes 17 points
the dependability yeah I think of some
very special it's like what does it look
like one zero yeah they're actually yeah
they have like one non-zero per column
yeah and that's it
but yeah what I sort of like to think
about SS okay computationally what it is
is it what what it really is is it's a
matrix it's an identity matrix where you
just deleted almost all the columns and
so therefore you're only selecting like
some subset of that yeah
you could be doing it from the Pinterest
base as well as that yeah actually like
for lowering yeah for lowering
approximation there's actually what
you're more typically doing I was just
throwing it on yeah it doesn't matter
what way the directions are going all of
our bounds they'll be for either
sampling data points or for sampling
features yeah sometimes it's more
interpretable for sampling features in
my opinion actually okay all right so
okay we have this bound this is the
bound that we're gonna target it's this
very simple spectral bound this bound
has been studied in a lot of different
contexts and it's sort of known how to
derive good sampling probabilities in
order to obtain this bound with good
probability so there's been some work in
matrix approximation literature also in
spectral graph theory algebra graph
theory trying to get these sorts of
bounds not necessarily all of these
works give actually slightly different
formulations but I want I'm going to
show you right now is like the sort of
cleanest formulation that we've come up
with which is this thing called a Ridge
leverage score this is what I'm gonna
define my sampling probability to be the
actual form of this doesn't matter too
much the point is at some score it's the
probability that I'm going to sample the
eyuth row of my matrix it depends on
that row it depends on the matrix it
also depends on this lambda this
additive error that I'm on allow myself
it's basically a quadratic form over the
inverse of matrix recognized by that
lambda the important properties are this
is one that it can be the sum of these
scores can be bounded as a function of
lambda and as a function of the matrix a
which is important because the sum of
the scores remember I'm sampling each
row independently with these scores the
sum of these scores is my expected
sample size so if I want to fast
algorithm I'm gonna need some way to
bound the sum of these scores the larger
lambda is the the smaller the son
becomes when lambda 0 this is for
example what I need to do
preconditioning or approximate system
solves the sum of the scores is at most
the rank of my matrix so as long as I
set as long as I select the number of
rows equal to the rank of my matrix I
get this thing with additive error
lambda equals zero for low-rank
approximation you can do things that are
a lot stronger if you appropriately set
lambda and I won't go into the details
here you can show that the sum of these
scores is less than or like for example
2k where you're looking for a rank K
approximation this means that when I
sample from my matrix an expectation I
get
two K rows meaning I get something like
usually order K rows I have this small
matrix I can perform an SVD on this
matrix which is reasonably inexpensive
it costs me maybe like D times K squared
time so this is a lot faster than doing
an SP in the original matrix and I can
get a near optimal low-rank
approximation of my original matrix so
it's critical that we're able to bound
we have good bounds on the sum of these
squares because that's going to be our
sample size constant mixtures of k-means
because a lot of these men look like
you're clustering the rows yeah it's
sort if you if you have your if you have
clustering your data it will sort of
appear also in these leverage scores
naturally what you'll tend to have is
that the leverage say the points the
points are really well clustered then
the leverage score of a row will be
roughly like 1 over the size of the
cluster that it's in if they're really
well clustered and then as it's sort of
a continuous interval continuously
interpolated as the data becomes less
well clustered yeah so this is one nice
thing as this isn't so far from it's
also really closely related to DPP's
like determine on two point processes
like the marginal distributions of DPP's
for example are like the appropriately
defined leverage square so it's not so
far what people do in practice but it's
sort of a cleaner it can give you some
cleaner guarantees when you sample ok is
there any way to make it K times a long
process well instead of a constant house
today
if your yeah no not really
so it depends is the pen sort of what
your if you're looking for here I'm
hiding epsilon factors really so I would
actually be say I'm looking for a
constant factor in optimal low-rank
approximation if I want to get say
something within point one of the
optimal you can prove that I better
select I need to at least look at like
ten rows ten times K row is my matrix so
you get like the budget there's only
like absolute percent of the okay like
if that's the number of rows I can
select any way to get to what a rational
approximation or something how does that
yeah I'm not really sure I don't know
that you can do that definitely though
there's way to run these algorithms like
I'll talk you later about kernel
approximation where I give a budget on
how much I want to sample and I sample
under that but typically the type of
guarantees you get is I give you a
sample of you can only sample K rows you
better only sample K rows but then you
maybe get an approximation bound which
is matching the best K over two
approximation right K over 2 yeah things
like that you have like trade-off there
all right okay so what have we
accomplished so far we basically tried
to take these problems that we care
about this linear system solving the
laureate approximation and write them as
a simple guarantee and this is let us
get a really nice sampling distribution
this leverage squared distribution that
we can prove gives good approximation if
we take enough samples and we also have
like an explicit data dependent formula
for this distribution so this is great
and we actually have the distribution in
hand
we've removed a lot of the ad hoc nough
some sampling for these problems what's
the problem is sort of if you look at
the form of this thing it's glaring is
that I have to compute solve a linear
system just to salt just to compute one
of these probabilities and I'm trying to
accelerate these sort of methods so
solving this linear system is generally
when we pretty much as hard as the
original problem I'm trying to solve and
we need to get around this and this is a
major contribution of our work what we
basically show is that we can officially
bootstrap the strap these leverage
scores from uniform sampling so I sort
of knocked on uniform sampling earlier I
said it doesn't often it
then cannot represent your matrix very
well but we can actually use it really
powerfully for approximating leopard
scores specifically what I can do is I
have my matrix I want to compute
leverage scores so that I can sample my
matrix accurately what I do is I first
uniform sample half the rows of the
matrix and then I want approximate
leverage scores in this really simple
way if my row is in my sample so if my
row AI is in the sample of one half this
will happen half the time then I'm just
going to compute the leverage scoring
the smaller matrix a bar if my row is
not in my matrix what I'm going to do is
I'm going to append it to the smaller
matrix I'm gonna sort of pretend that I
sampled it and I'm gonna puke the
leverage scoring this larger matrix a
bar with the row appended so I'm just
gonna approximate the leverage squares
by cutting my matrix in half and then
basically computing Laboratories in this
smaller matrix and hope that these
things actually will approximate my
original scores and this is what we're
going to show we're going to show that
overall these approximate leverage
scores are good approximations to the
true leverage scores yeah yes so this
would be the next slide actually yeah
wait so second kind of thing you can do
if you don't get pre computed for every
row this thing yeah yeah in the end what
this one I'll show you but it's gonna be
a rank one update we don't first of all
it yeah it will be a rank one update to
the universe so you can do that
efficiently actually what you can do is
something even simpler where you just
compute the leverage score in this
matrix and you and you use the minimum
of that leverage score in one the
probability one so you can actually use
an even simpler algorithm you don't need
to actually compute this out yeah okay
so why is this enough so because you can
iterate this process so I want to
compute the leverage scores in this
matrix a bar this requires computing
some linear system solving some
computing some like quadratic form over
the inverse of a bar which is half the
size of my original matrix but it's
still pretty big Plus maybe a rank 1
perturbation which I could deal with
efficiently in a number of ways but the
problem is a bar still too big so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
recursively approximate a bar using
leverage we're sampling ok so what does
that look like I start with my original
matrix I cut it in half to get a bar one
to call that my first uniform sample
this is still too big to work with so I
cut it in half again to get a bar to I
keep cutting in half
like finally get to a matrix that I can
actually work with note that this is
just a uniform sample of my matrix and I
can maybe I stopped when I can fit in a
memory I stopped on as one grow whatever
and then what I do is say I went down to
two levels I use a bar to to approximate
the leverage scores for a bar 1 a bar 2
is just a uniform sample of a bar 1 but
my claim on the previous slide I can do
a good job approximating that it's
leverage worse I can then sample from a
bar 1 to get a good approximation to a
bar 1 and then what I can show is that
this approximation can be used to
approximate the leverage squares of a
itself a bar 1 could be used to
approximate these average scores it's
not very hard to show that a a tilde 1
can also approximate these average
scores and so finally I worked my way up
to the top level of the computation and
I compute the leverage scores reasonably
accurately ok so that's the entire
algorithm the key is just proving that
uniform sampling if I uniform sample and
1/2 this computes leverage words that's
all we need to prove to get this thing
to work ok so this is what we need to
show we need to show that our
approximate leverage scores which we got
from uniform sampling are good
approximations and to do this we
actually need to really natural
properties of the leverage squares 1 we
need that they're bounded by something
so for linear systems in that case
they're bounded by the rank of the
matrix when you appropriately set lambda
for low-rank approximation they're
bounded by some universal upper bound to
K where to K where K is the rank of the
approximation you care about it's
natural that they're bounded they better
be bounded or else because we're
sampling by them so if they're not
bounded that we don't know how big our
sample size is going to be so we use
that they're bounded and that they're
monotonic which is just means that if I
remove rows from my matrix the leverage
scores of the remaining rows only go up
and this is a very natural property for
an import sampling metric of Rho can
only get more important as other rows
that leave ok so how can we use these to
prove that these approximate leverage
stories are good the first claim is that
my approximate leverage scores are only
larger than my true leverage scores so
this means I'm really going to sample
every row and my final process on a
sample every row with some slightly
higher probability than I should have
but this is fine I'm only gonna do a
better approximation if I sample more
rows how do I get this well this follows
immediately by monotonicity
so in the first case I'm just computing
a leverage query against a bar that
contains half the rows of my matrix the
leverage scores of the remaining rows
have only increased over their original
value so I approximately over
approximate in that case and same with
in the second case I'm looking at a bar
Union AI this is still a subset of my
matrix the importance of AI in this
subset is only more important than its
importance in the whole matrix so I have
that I have over approximation sell
average scores and then what I need to
show is that the expected some of the
leverage scores that remember that the
sum of the true leverage scores was
something like 2k I need to show the
expected some of these approximate
leverage scores aren't that much larger
so my sample size is roughly the same
size so they over approximate my sample
probabilities but not by so much and
this is all I need to get a fast
algorithm I'm not going to show you the
proof of this but it's really easy to
prove you basically and so this is what
this is what it gives you you basically
use an averaging argument you show that
the average leverage score in in a bar
Union AI is not too large and then you
sum up these expectations and you show
that this expectation is a too large so
it's actually super easy to prove this
you only need the monotonicity property
and this bound in this property actually
I don't think you need the monotonicity
property for that one okay so that's it
so what's the upshot we show that
uniform sampling can be we define some
nice importance measure and we show that
it can be well approximated with uniform
sampling yeah oh yeah so so you don't
have a uniform constant value throughout
all the iterations
you do so I'm wondering what because
you're going to go from you know and
yeah whoever forward it's on and is this
big ol uniform and all these iteration
or this is just for the first iteration
it is uniform well so there's a little
details on hiding under the rug which is
you need to set land like say we were
doing linear systems in lambda was 0
this would be this value K would be like
D it would be rank of the matrix okay if
lambda is 0 and always this would be
bounded by something like 4 times the
rank of the matrix something like
uniform for every single iteration if
the rank your matrix happens to go down
when you sample then it might get a
little bit better but it's never going
to be worse than the rank of the
original matrix in low-rank
approximation setting it's bounded by
some constant times the statistical
dimension or the sort of the stable rank
of the initial matrix this thing is
going to only again go down as you
sample so it is really bounded by some
you know formula i mean well it's
bounded by better and better things as
you go down but a worst case by the top
increasing so how could you go down as
as you the leverage squares are
increasing but you're removing rows so
the sum of the leverage squares is
actually only going down for staying the
same i mean yeah yeah okay
okay so this is a fad so okay the upshot
is we use uniform sampling to
approximately these leverage course
these leverage scores give approximation
for a lot of problems it gives us a fast
generic important sampling algorithm for
a lot of linear algebraic problems so
you can't actually bound okay so you
can't actually say that lambda told for
example is within a constant factor of
every I mean so you can't actually say
like total de is within a constant
factor of tau for every single I in some
cases for example like tau I might be 0
and tau till there might be some
positive number so you can't bound them
so you just have that in aggregate the
the do you have a constant factor
approximation so the sum of the
approximated ones are only a constant
factor higher than the sum of the real
ones and you use these other sampling
probability so it means you take a
constant factor a larger sample so it's
sort of you pay it as a runtime cost the
difference understand what he was asking
eventually also have the same question
so by sampling once you losing the
constant so you usually you start with
some big bouquet and then you must come
from faster why this constant doesn't
can be gate over well because well this
is the approach Arab out this for one
level so my sample once I lose but I
don't really care about I don't care I'm
gonna ignore the leverage squares of the
top level for a minute I just want to
approximate the leverage squares of the
second level so yeah you don't you don't
pay you're not trying to approximate the
leverage squares of the top level with
for example the third level you only you
first sample this you first sample a1
and you get some approximations which
say you get like a constant factor
spectral proximation at n factor then
what the constants gonna blow up by from
going from a 1 to a is something like 10
times 2 or something and then you fix
this in every single iteration so it
doesn't blow up I use that make sense
yeah
but yeah things yeah roughly speaking
things don't balloon I'm sure it's
because you can always pay for if you
have enough if you have approximate
scores you can always sort of correct
for this by just over sampling by a
constant factor and now you have just as
good of approximation as you would have
gotten so it's as if the rest of the
recursion didn't matter at all and now
you just look at one level and you
complete that level and you keep going
okay so the upshot is these fast generic
and foreign sampling algorithms you can
get nice asymptotic runtimes
you can get things that basically match
linear sketching methods or stochastic
gradient where you're paying for sort of
like order 1 times the number of
non-zeros and your matrix plus some
smaller term like this DK squared term
for low-rank approximation and it's
really easy to adapt em to streaming
online and distributed settings because
it's not you can sort of easily sort of
distribute your combination of these
leverage scores and then merge them back
together at the end but more importantly
than these exact runtimes is that you
can apply this methods and contexts
where previous approaches like
traditional iterative methods or random
sketching completely fail so I'm gonna
give you an example of that for kernel
methods in kernel methods basically I am
trying to learn some nonlinear
relationship amongst my data I do this
by replacing my standard inner product
with some nonlinear inner product this
kernel function kxixj and maybe it's
like the Gaussian kernel which I showed
up there and this implicitly defines
this n by n kernel matrix where every
entry is the inner product between data
point X and dinner or data point I and
data point J now even writing down this
kernel matrix takes N squared time I
might not want to explicitly write it
down but even do like in a single
iteration of a linear system solver on
this kernel matrix am trying to solve
regression in this kernel matrix this
takes n squared time we're applying a
single round of random projection or
hashing this also takes N squared time
so this is really expensive even if n is
200,000 if it's not even that big of a
data set I have 40 billion entries it
will typically be a dense matrix it
takes 300 gigabytes to store this thing
just becomes very unwieldy especially if
I go up to like millions of
points then suddenly this is just not
possible to run to work with this kernel
matrix so basically all implementations
of kernel methods at large scale use
low-rank approximation you always take
your kernel and you approximate it by
some product C Z transpose where it has
some limited number of columns you can
store this lot less space you can do
computation lot more efficiently you
basically need to do this and you get
some sort of linear and and run time
which is important and there's a lot of
methods for computing kernel
approximations in linear times things
based on incomplete chil-su
factorization this nice draw method is
especially popular there's this
well-known technique called random for
feature sampling which can be viewed as
giving a low-rank approximation of your
matrix all these things run in roughly
linear an end time but that means that
there for example not computing every
entry of the kernel matrix and they have
to pay for this in the end they never
give error that's comparable so ideally
I don't want the best ranked ass
approximation to my kernel matrix
computing this would be super expensive
if I wanted to do it even using an
iterative method even if my editor
method completed in one iteration would
take N squared time so these things are
doing something much more limited to
that and they're never getting
approximation in terms of this
best-ranked s approximation what we can
show with the leverage for sampling is
we can actually close this gap sort of
surprisingly we show that you can
actually get a linear time method that
gives a near optimal low-rank
approximation and sort of the sense that
you want which is this we start with
this basic thing called nice term then
you're sorry so by linear time i mean
linear an and it will be quite shallow
these visitors as you use derivatives
yeah okay yeah so yeah I'll explain that
I'll explain what exactly I mean yeah so
be n times the number thus times the
size of your original input yeah yeah
we're sort of like inin yes so we got a
method that does this let me explain so
we base it actually I'm sort of running
on time so I'm going to skip the exact
basis of I'm at the but let me just tell
you what the result is Oh actually no
fine I'll explain so we you we base it
off this thing called die strong
approximation which is basically like
you sample some landmark data points
from your data set and you form some
approximation based off the Sam
you can view this as basically sampling
some points in kernel space so a big way
that you work with kernel methods is
that you write the kernel as an inner
product between vectors in some higher
dimensional space sometimes an infinite
dimensional space so I'm being really
informal here but think about these as
high dimensional vectors I sample points
in this space and I project the rest of
my points to them and that's how I
approximate my kernel matrix what we can
show is that if you sample these
landmark points with their Ridge
leverage scores in kernel space and you
sample something like s over epsilon
landmarks then you can get an
approximation not of the kernel matrix K
but of this like kernel eyes data set
where every row is one of the is one of
your kernel eyes data points you can get
a near optimal approximation to this so
basically the approximation produced by
Nystrom is within 1 plus epsilon of the
optimal lower rank approximation of this
matrix in your runtime is linear and n
in quadratic in s where it's linear and
end of the number of kernel evaluations
you have to compute and then it's in
them the additional computation you need
is linear and quadratic in s and it
doesn't for compute the entire kernel
matrix and ok we also get bounds for a
bunch of other problems basically by
going through these spectral guarantees
and this closes a big gap between linear
time methods which are basically the
only thing you can run in practice and
actually like getting some sort of nice
near optimal approximation about and
practically speaking it works really
well so I've plotted run times here the
important part is that we're this blind
we compared to these other linear time
methods that don't give like a near
optimal approximation to the kernel and
we're way faster than the quadratic time
which essentially just doesn't scale and
then our approximation error it's
somewhere in between these methods but
it's going down much faster a lot of
these times these other methods sort of
stagnate once you get to a certain
number of samples order is actually
going down much much faster and much
closer to what you get with the random
approximate with this slow method which
is in this case random projection
bleh-bleh right no all right how really
miss blue line so black line is like if
you if you took your kernel matrix and
apply to random projection which
actually is really expensive because you
have to compute the kernel yeah so we're
not going to we don't do as well as that
but we do
you know much better than the LZ
proposal sounds a little bit uh yes well
so the thing is is that I can't compute
it's hard to compute these approximation
errors it requires computing the
spectrum of a super-large mate so the
reason this is small is because it's
actually I'm pretty small I'm these
matrices are not very large it's just
this goes to show scaling yeah okay um I
guess something a little low on time so
let me just briefly summarize an even
more surprising result you can get which
comes out of these kernel methods which
is that I give you any PSD and this is
again using these Ridge leverage square
sampling techniques I give you any PSD
matrix I can output a near optimal
low-rank approximation and the runtime
is something like n K squared over some
pi know my own epsilon note that my
matrix I have no assumptions on this
matrix so it could be dense it could
have n squared entries
it could have terrible condition number
it could be very incoherent yet I don't
need to read this matrix and I can still
get in your optimal or anchored
proximation to it and this is just by
bootstrapping this sort of kernel
algorithm we factor the PSD matrix as
its square root times itself if we
applied kernel the kernel approximation
algorithm you can work through our
bounds you'd see that we'd approximate
the square root of this matrix which
isn't the same as approximating the
matrix itself but we show is that you
can do something better you can
basically sample rows and columns the
matrix by the leverage squares of this
square root you can do it efficiently
and you can get down to this core of the
matrix which contains very few rows and
columns and from this you can extract a
near optimal rank approximation the
details don't really matter but it's
sort of so I thought that this was
surprising the only structural property
we exploit from the matrix is that it's
positive semi definite and then we don't
need to read the whole matrix and we can
get
yes so this is like first of all this is
like our bound I don't know that it's
actually the right thing but it probably
is at least one over epsilon we have a
lower bound of one over epsilon and it
probably at least one over epsilon
squared
but even if for example you apply like a
cop if you apply like a constant factor
often you're seeing your tail of your
matrix fall off really quickly so you're
not looking for like really good epsilon
you just care about getting most of the
mass your matrix and you're paying
alright so I think I guess I don't know
does this end at half pastors like
that's like yeah so why don't I wrap up
on the the linear algebra section I can
take questions on it and then if people
want to stay I can talk about the bio
stuff where I can just skip it we can
decide okay so okay this is a summary
what was the right way to select data
points and features for linear algebraic
computation we considered simple
important strategy sampling strategies
we defined like a very clear spectral
approximation goal and this let us
define very clear probabilities we then
made this algorithmic and efficient by
bootstrapping uniform sampling and we're
getting some pretty powerful results for
kernel methods and for PSD matrices and
hopefully we can get more powerful
results in areas where other Animas
methods don't really suffice in this
talk I mostly talked about sampling
one-shot sampling I have a big matrix
and I want to approximate it once but
obviously you can use sampling in a lot
of other ways so one obvious one is this
part of iterative methods and
understanding how you can use sampling
for example to speed up like
second-order methods is a really big
question in a sort of alternative way of
using it in linear algebra you can use
second these methods these iterative
methods to give fast algorithms as I
mentioned for lots of linear algebraic
problems so it's a really interesting
area to look at and also we've been
interested recently in generalizing this
word beyond basic linear algebraic
problem for example - like sampling for
your features we've used this
specifically for kernel approximation
but hopefully it can be used in other
Fourier analysis computation in
Sandpoint fourier techniques and maybe
for other types of models in the last
thing I'll mention is that I've been
talking this entire time about how
important like randomness is and
approximation in these
showing you we don't really actually
understand if I don't know that this is
really true so I'll tell you one fact
which is that any fast algorithm on a
matrix so basically anything that runs
in faster than order N squared n cube
time or faster than fast matrix
multiplication time if you want to think
about that uses one of two techniques
either it makes assumptions on the
matrix assumes something like boundary
condition number or bounded eigenvalue
bound so this is how you get classic
iterative methods or it does what we're
doing it uses randomization it pays
these 1 over epsilon squared or 1 over
epsilon to the 4th factors all
algorithms I know of except for doing
something like computing the trace or
something for any non-trivial problem
they aren't fall into one of these two
paradigms and we want to explain why
this is like is there anything else we
can do do we really need to be using
randomization approximation in order to
get around assumptions or there some
class of faster rounds that we just
don't know about you but simple a really
simple question just as a thought is
like it's not even knowing how to
deterministically compute an
approximation to the see top singular
value of a matrix without computing a
flag in any composition is this the bet
really the best we can do can you prove
that it should be the best we can do or
it can or is this or really stuck there
ok so I'll close on that and then yeah I
can take question general questions
[Applause]
pictures of ants and stuff that would be
yeah I can do that ok yeah yeah then
you're out there's a lot boring than it
more boring than answer originally so ok
let me try to just I'll just tell you
exactly the thing that we've studied so
what we've been interesting is is
understanding there's all these
biological systems that are essentially
running randomized algorithms ants
essentially run like a randomized
algorithms and not only do they run them
we know of what they're running because
biologists can probe their behavior and
figure out how does this ant make this
decision what's the input that that
causes them to make this certain
decision but biologists don't really
have a good way of analyzing you figure
out how all of these things fit together
so the process that we've been studying
is basically
there's these certain ants these rock
ants that basically they have to they
have to do this process of when their
nest becomes too small because their
colony grew a lot or when their nest is
destroyed for some reason they have to
go find a new nest and they have to do
this in a distributed way so there's no
central controller to say look for a new
nest and move to it so the algorithm
that they run is first some scout agents
some small subset of population they
notice that their nest is messed up for
whatever reason and they start going and
looking for new nest sites they assess
these nest sites and they can do this
each individual ant is complex enough to
actually assess the quality of a nest
site they can roughly measure its size
they can raise or how much light is in
there so sort of how protected it is
from the elements and things like this
so they get some sort of really coarse
approximation to its quality both of
these things are arraigned them they're
not like doing some sort of grid search
or something they're just randomly
walking around and then when they see a
nest site they assess its quality in
this trigger something if it's above a
certain threshold they make a decision
this decision is that they decide to
recruit other Scouts to try to assess
this nest quality so if the nest is good
enough they go back to the home nest
they randomly walk around they randomly
bump into another ant and then they try
to recruit it to actually do an its own
assessment its own independent
assessment of the nest it does its own
random assessment they keep doing this
process eventually it builds up to a
sort of quorum threshold of ants that
actually think this new nest is like a
good nest and then what they this is
also a random process that's why I
haven't it what they then do is they
decide on this nests so if there's
enough Scouts that are somehow
recruiting to this nest they can
actually sense this it triggers
something in their mind where they say
this is our new home and then what they
do is they initiate a decision-making
process what they do is they actually
move the entire rest of the colony over
to this new nest site and this is sort
of necessary because a lot of the agents
in the colony are unknowable so the
queen is in mobile the brood is in
mobile there's a lot of ants that for
whatever reason understood you just sit
around do anything what they do is they
literally go back to the nest they pick
up the other ants and they just carry
them to this new nest site and this is
how they move and so this is like well
they're trying to analyze the other so
this is like it's actually a super well
understood algorithm by
just like know exactly what they're
doing they can test things like for
example they can test if they can
prevent the ants from reaching quorum
threshold they literally do things like
put skirts around the ants little wire
skirt so they can't interact with other
ants and then they notice that for
example they'll never reach corn
threshold because they can never detect
when it when they're bumping into other
ants and things like that so they can
really test what they're doing the
question becomes analyze what they're
doing why is it working with good
probability for them and also like why
are they doing it how do they do how is
the quorum threshold decided so should
the quorum threshold increases colony
size increases or should it be
independent of the size of the colony
should it have something to do with the
number of potential nest sites in the
area do they adapt it or is it just
fixed answering all these questions is
really interesting questions for
biologists and their questions that we
have the tools to solve so yeah so
usually it's in a lab setting and okay
there's some parameters you have to
decide what makes a good nest but
usually you set up a nest in a lab
setting that for example some nests will
have a closed top which is good for them
because it's more protected some will
have no top at all some will have a
small entrance which is easy to fence
some will have a large entrance so you
can sort of some vague understanding of
what mean what good yes so this is sort
of the fail case I mean one fail case is
getting a bad nest the fail case that
happens more often at least in my
Hobson's but it doesn't seem to happen
for whatever reason in natures they
split the Queen can only go to one of
those colonies so the other colony will
die out unless they move usually what
happens is they do move so usually what
happens is if the nests are close enough
they also have a process where they
notice that there's two nests and then
they eventually recombine but it often
takes a long time yeah you don't have
like a fight over that because I don't
think they're coordinated enough to do
that but like in general yeah if you end
up in a mess without the Queen in that
subset of the population we're just
basically that don't die off I mean not
the individual hands but yeah so you
mentioned the relative acceleration is
very good at understanding how high
quality their random number generators
are
I don't sew no wait did you use random
imprecise so in Sarandon I use I said
okay this is the only way that I've seen
this studied well I as I'm get to on the
next slide
alright let me let me let me answer on
one second so we have some work trying
to understand this core in very old
strategies and when it's effective and
why it's useful and it has close
connections not surprisingly with like
distributed consensus protocols and then
we also have some work on zooming in on
one primitive that these ants use which
is estimating population density this is
what they use tasks to make or in
threshold so there's a high density in a
nest
this means that probably more Scouts are
trying to recruit there and then they're
more likely to be in quorum and that
it's a good time to move to that nest
and so how do they estimate population
density well they walk around randomly
and they count the number of times that
they bump into another ant the more
times they bump into another ant the
higher the density the less times the
lower the density okay and what we do is
we basically analyze this process and
give some sort of analysis about why
they're able to analyze density and why
this is a vice is for something like
quorum threshold now our analysis
assumes that they're literally random
walking agents which is certainly not
true what you can do to sort of try to
at least test whether the analysis so
what some people have done at least
attest to some degree whether the
analysis holds although you would need
to do more work is for example take
videos of these ants label them you know
label them individually and count the
number of collisions you have between
different ants and then look at the
distributions the moments of this
distribution how many times you collide
with other ants and then you can say is
this about what you'd expect if they
were walking around from you know from
AI random so like some people have
actually done work on this like
following up on our work and they do
show that it is close to what you'd
expect from uniform distribution of
assumptions yes yeah exactly so at least
to some degree this random assumption is
decent and you could prevent lead Euler
things so you can try to test it like to
some degree I think that's it actually
there's close connections with social
like so
estimating population density is not so
different from estimating area the area
that you're spread out over and there's
close connections estimating the size of
social networks via sampling so we show
some connections there so that I'll wrap
up I can take questions then the ants
are also on the
any kind of intervention doing the
process like you deliberately change the
potential nest or a glib release yeah
yes yes yes so yeah so this is the 1i
one example I was saying was with these
are these metal skirts what they'll do
is they'll let the answer run mostly
that run the process mostly and then
they'll somehow restrict their movement
or restrict so that you can see whether
or not the end up making they would have
made a decision and you stopped them
from making the decision or the very
beginning you stopped them in this
experiment that I'm talking about you
actually stopped them after they've
already investigated and also run some
recruited some other ants that nest and
stuff there's also other yeah I mean
there's a lot of like really cool I mean
I don't actually do like I don't design
these experiments this is like we're
working with people that design these
experiments but they do a lot of like
physical things like for example there's
a lot of studying and how they can
cooperatively transport large pieces of
food which is something they do a lot in
there you can put four sensors on this
fake food you can put four sensors and
you can try to figure out exactly what
they're doing
so you said many of your algorithms for
sampling you could display they can also
and this is to build a model so what
exactly the distributed model yeah sorry
because like I think like even dove
specification and things I don't know
whether they can be solved in stupid
settings well I'm just vaguely saying
that I'm talking about a model where I
have a number of servers say they're
well connected to each other and each of
them hold some subset of my data yeah
it's really natural distribute our
algorithms these sorts of models because
you can compute leverage squares
separately on the data sets and by this
nice monotonicity property you can
really easily merge your samples
together and you can sort of dance so I
compute leverage squares separately on
the different subsets of my data i
sample it down to get some sort of small
subset and then I can recombine when I
recombine my leverage squares only
decrease and then I can sample them out
basically so I'm not talking about a
model for example where every single
data point is its own server or
something like this yeah I'm not talking
about those models yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah so people that I work with that yes
that specification in that is too big
model is quite I think this is now like
know that there's some recent progress
on this using like random like sarandon
spanner type methods and then yeah but
either way but yeah it is important
questions but I'm not thinking about
those sorts of models are
[Applause]